[Music]
all right let's bring you the latest
lines coming out of pakistan where the
national assembly has confirmed shabash
sharif as the country's new prime
minister
sharif
succeeds imran khan you'll recall of
course that he was ousted in a rather
dramatic no-confidence vote over the
weekend
more than a hundred mps
of khan's pakistan tahrir party well
they decided to resign at in protest
against his ousting
tens of thousands also rallied in
support of khan on sunday night
is in islamabad for us so osama pakistan
has a new prime minister now right
absolutely shabbat sharif is now the
23rd prime minister of pakistan the
official announcement is to be made
momentarily uh as votes have been cast
and this was a done deal
when the opposit opposition party now uh
pakistan terry can save imran khan's
party decided that they are going to
boycott this vote so now there is no
opposition uh to the election of shabbat
sharif who is now the new prime minister
of pakistan we have to see how many
votes have been cast in his favor as the
assembly session is underway uh the
results have been compiled and they've
been presented to the speaker and he's
asked all uh members of the parliament
to come back inside the assembly so it's
been a dramatic day in a dramatic week
of events where you've seen a vote of no
confidence against imran khan the
speaker striking it down the court
coming into action calling it
unconstitutional and illegal and then
the assembly is being reinstated which
were resolved by the president and
finally a vote of confidence taking
place and while all of this was
happening imran khan's party decided
that they are going to not just boycott
the vote but they are going to resign
from the assemblies more than 140 mps
expected to resign from the national
assembly those resignations have been
circulated on social media but they have
not reached uh the speaker's chambers
yet um so the formalities will take
place but imran khan's party insisting
that they do not want to be part of what
they call an imported setup alluding to
uh what uh
iraq has been stating all along that
this is an international conspiracy uh
this is a foreign-backed government and
he does not want to be part of it it is
interesting that imran khan also said
that he is going to fight these
politicians in the assembly but now has
decided that he is now going to take to
the streets and try and force an early
election
and osama judging by the street protests
we've seen so far does it look like this
might not be the end of this political
dispute but rather just the beginning
absolutely this is uh imran khan you
have to remember is a popular politician
here his party did have the majority uh
when they uh when before the coalition
came together
and got the numbers and because of the
performance of imran khan in the last
three and a half years many of his
coalition partners felt that they they
were not being given enough they were
not being treated equally and he was
failing to deliver on those promises and
they said that's why they changed
sides towards the opposition imran khan
saying that their votes were bought
there was a lot of money involved but
now it seems that pakistan has a new
steward in place now this 23rd prime
minister of pakistan shaba sharif is
going to be facing down a number of
challenges not just political
uncertainty but grave challenges to the
economy as well pakistan is still in
talks with the international monetary
fund for a next tranche uh to try and
bail out its economy uh there is some
stability in the pak rupee versus the us
dollar but there are it concerns there
as well and obviously the biggest
concern that people have is rising
inflation uh which has been spiraling in
the last few years uh but shabbat sharif
is somebody who's seen in pakistan
as someone who has a can-do attitude and
has a track record of delivering
when the situation got tough especially
in pakistan's biggest province punjab
known in pakistan as an administrator
who gets things done
at the age of 70 shabbat sharif was the
joint leader of the opposition that
toppled imran khan in a no-confidence
vote
sharif entered politics and then led
pakistan's most populous province and
the major infrastructure projects
in his hometown lahore he successfully
brought in investment from china and
turkey
he's also had good relations with the
u.s analysts say he will need to mend
fences after the outgoing prime minister
accused his opponents of being
politically manipulated by washington
shahbaz is the younger brother of former
prime minister nima sharif who was
dismissed following allegations of
corruption
he's facing a money laundering case and
corruption charges brought by the
federal investigation agency and the
national accountability bureau both
brothers say the allegations leveled
under imran khan's premiership were
politically motivated and in 2007 sharif
criticized the accountability bureau
investigating him nab
which is uh an institution uh you know
construed by musharraf equine to
hitler's uh you know gestapo
uh national accountability bureau which
does selective accounting accountability
and other opposition politicians also
accused it of being a tool used for
political witch-hunts in subsequent
years in power the muslim league
government left the bureau unchanged
out of all politicians shaba sharif is
widely considered to be the most
acceptable to the military establishment
and those who came together to topple
imran khan's government are hoping that
the army will maintain what it calls its
neutral status
even if shaybas sharif remains the prime
minister until elections next year he
will still not become a prime minister
who completes a five-year term in
pakistan as none have done in the
country's 75-year history
islamabad
[Music]